[Music]
in wrong Tiffani news hmm Wow wrong or
she's not the right Tiffany I'm not the
right submitted by long no okay
Costco must pay Tiffany and company 19
million after mislabeling the jewelry
sold in their stores so they just called
generic jewelry Tiffany's jewelry
without they did however not heard of
this before that so they just use a
different flawed like aa
your Tiffany's our Tiffany's is
different that's crazy cuz they do sell
name-brand stuff in there yeah oh yeah
dude that's biggie
yeah that's pretty bad cuz they could
mark that [ __ ] up probably made
big-league right to participate was just
saying yes I felt like that like that
Tiffany should I feel like you'd like
this sure I don't have anything Tiffany
oh I do but I don't wear it
you'd be like it right not really okay
Tiffany like Stephanie yeah cuz it's
certainly not a lot of stuff I don't
like I like the movie Breakfast at
Tiffany's
I think if any one here likes Tiffany's
completely how did I miss that I would
know I've never gotten anything from
Tiffany's oh yeah that's just crazy
though I have been gifted to me but
what's so special about Tiffany's is
that marketing I recognize Tiffany's but
I also recognize the Robbins brothers
they're nervous you're not gonna be able
to recognize Rob as brothers
Tiffany's was founded in 1837 and
they're like the leading jewelry brand
they have like exclusive designs all
those other jewelry companies they have
very generic looks there's certain like
Tiffany style chain links or whatever
same thing and I think they even
trademarked that color it's daddy's blue
it's only they can use that color really
not only that but they actually invented
a new type of setting so before
Tiffany's the settings were always in
like a full shallow cup of metal and so
now like Tiffany's actually invented the
prong
Kong Tiffany setting something interests
so that's the thing here so there are
the pioneers of the jewelry game is why
they got so famous yeah they're like the
world's leading jeweler so yeah so then
this whole Costco thing here so Tiffany
is a diamond maker you know they're like
a jeweler jeweler yeah
so this Tiffany lady she invented [ __ ]
this the way that the jeweler he said
explain history to keep children George
Washington's like the [ __ ] prisoners
no I'm just okay so sometimes when
there's a name right there's a person
behind the name like sometimes like
Roberta's tacos okay so it's not really
a Victoria the secret is there's no
Victoria really oftentimes because of
the way that we're so su happy as a
society they make up a name and don't
have it be their name because you could
be personally sued if your name is in
the company Tiffany so Roberta's taco is
probably not actually Roberta what just
saying probably Rosie yeah so the
cofounders of Tiffany & Company is
Charles Lewis Tiffany and John be young
Oh
answer all of your questions yeah
awesome now it's two actually two old
guys with like aprons in that monocle no
jewelry when they founded it yeah okay
but they when they became super
successful I just pictured two old guys
with the monocle and a [ __ ] apron and
they're like making jewelry but before
that I pictured a sweet old lady that
was like the jewelry like God and
everybody went to Tiffany to get their
diamond rings and all these necklaces
and stuff so you projected a back story
that was completely not yeah so I kept
wondering who the [ __ ] is this Tiffany
that everyone's talking about I'll give
you some more history so they first
opened a stationery and fancy goods
store with $1,000
advanced from Tiffany's father that's
how he started and then they went into
going in like silk satin bonnet and then
eventually diamonds
so anyways back to Costco the whole
Costco think they invented the setting
of with the prongs it's a really generic
term to call it like a Tiffany setting
so it's kind of like Kleenex now like
how we were forgetting to shoes it oh
yeah
what Costco was doing is that they were
labeling generic rings as Tiffany rings
they weren't specifying if it was like a
Tiffany setting or whatever so they
actually sold about 2,500 diamond rings
that were falsely identified as Tiffany
rings and so the judge they were just
generic rings yeah but in the Tiffany
setting yeah
yeah exactly so then that's why they
would label as Tiffany so customers were
led to believe that they were buying a
Tiffany and company product when in fact
there was not even any word and their
cost goes like this shit's [ __ ] me
granted Tiffany's okay here's like that
kind of [ __ ] I can see my dad doing that
that's why I go weird every penny like
that kind of [ __ ] they even have gym
membership or like the garage door pick
about gasoline yeah I love Costco get a
hot dog there they're our daughter's
dollar churros I still can't tell the
difference between the polish and the
all beets what I like I like I'll be
I've been saying that for years
you can't tell that there is no
difference don't even look different
I think the polish is just a little bit
longer engineering
one's a little bit darker too I think
the all-beef is the darker one I just
know if you get the chicken baked you're
a [ __ ] little [ __ ] it is we all used
to go after it like after high school
you get a [ __ ] chicken big nah dude
you can't hang out with us go sit
another table if you did the hot dog or
the pizza exactly that's it
what about an ice cream that
it's our show that they have which is
recent I don't remember them having
salad but you didn't get this up have
you guys ever bought the Costco hotdogs
like because that was all the marketing
right is like oh you could actually buy
all the food inside right have you
bought the hot dog pizza - yeah you
could buy the tent no but like frozen
yeah you can yeah to see meats again
dude gasps go bakery is so good like
their rosemary you cost my mother
sponsors that snack bar
that Costco water though that Kirkland
brand is pretty good solid brand you
know it's fine
everything from Gospels kind of do isn't
it yeah Costco has a special place in my
heart because you know when my uncle was
bored and he's like let's go eat
he would take me to Costco on the
weekends and we would sample all the
places and just go home well we'll see
who really likes Costco right here uh
what color is your membership card wait
I don't have like black minds blood
that's like executive cars oh I thought
it was length of time I was getting
really excited what's the difference the
difference is that's like crazy rare
dude ha the difference is that's crazy
rare congratulations cuz I know one of
the cards also qualifies you for Costco
the commercial one yeah that's the one I
have free way with a normal card II
can't get into there yeah and they
opened earlier that one's for like
business owners you guys should start a
family you can't you can all right you
can't be kept by anything
I tried by something they won't let me
buy it when I was 13 I was getting
bullied a lot and yeah thank you and
after school yep the only thing that I
had to look forward to where I wouldn't
get bullied
was my neighborhood Costco Costco they
really protected you there huh they had
my back oh is that's a real quality
company quality organization well you're
gonna be happy about this
so Costco is planning to appeal that
court decision of
then having to pay 19 million back
that's awesome
don't let don't get bullied Costco by
Tiffany's yeah worked burgers you're not
getting bullied they were [ __ ] lying
they should by Tiffany they could really
lying it's this name of this fatty that
was deceiving
POTUS goes nice guy you don't know
possible the way I know Costco apostles
okay sir no they're saying that the
decision was a product of multiple
errors and that it wasn't the case of
counterfeiting they were saying that
Costco is not selling imitation Tiffany
& Company rings certain people like out
of the 2500 rings that were sold
apparently Tiffany only identified fewer
than ten people who said they
misunderstood Costco signage something
Costco's like you see we really deceive
people it was just less than 10 people
we deceived so they're gonna be
appealing that hold and they're gonna be
appealing that using their Costco lawyer
membership which you can also get good
yeah but it comes in a card and yet the
redeeming in the front to I'm curious
why businesses don't just say like dude
so we have this dude who's in charge of
this chairs name is Antonio he [ __ ] up
he's a [ __ ]
I'm sorry guys he this is his fifth time
[ __ ] up I don't know why we keep him
here
like what abysus do that [ __ ] I would do
that that's like when you're at Walmart
and some guy mislabeled a video game or
some [ __ ] where the guns the
back-to-school things know what's that
one so they had a gun display and they
actually labeled it as like essentials
rebecc-- to score or something like that
but it was gun and so Walmart was like
apologize business apologize it looks
like that [ __ ] was like known throughout
the whole entire corporation it could be
like sorry guys John here I I was in
charge of doing that I was [ __ ]
stoned that day wasn't paying attention
and it kind of happened you know sorry
that's like the cat did you ever the cat
who he's set up a whole 9/11 memorial
display with coke with coca-cola and
Coke Zero and Diet Coke products so it
like looked like 9/11 like kind of like
it looked like the Twin Towers and like
like you know
yeah yeah and of course like you know
they have to they have to publicly
apologize like hey you know Albertsons
is super sorry about that
but like you're some [ __ ] [ __ ]
like you said there's some guys all like
all of their 50 stores or whatever it's
one guy that's like it took it upon
myself to do it sorry you know that's
all we need I hope you guys enjoy this
video for more please subscribe to our
Channel and you can check out the last
video right here
[Music]